this is what I'm talking about we need
this in the freakin United States of
America why do we not have protests like
this I don't care if it's gonna be
brutal and violent or whatever we need
this because politicians in the US are
not getting it through their frickin
heads there were the protests in
Berkeley people were beaten within an
inch of their life violent protests
trash cans it really wasn't a protest it
was a riot the ante fuh which is a
domestic terrorist group and their
social justice warrior ilk decided to
write in protests throughout the streets
and it became a national story
well shank we ger over there are our
favorite resident Armenian Genocide and
I are actually had a different theory as
to how these protests or riots erupted
and so and and could the right-wing come
in masked couldn't be 4chan guys who
come in to cause trouble so that they
can then turn around and do exactly what
they got to take away the funding from
Berkeley I mean they're teaching science
over there where they're teaching facts
we hate tributing motive based on fire
we just had you guys don't understand
how problematic all of this is right
yeah problematic first of all if it was
a clever strategy by the right
congratulations it's working so don't
play into it okay but even if it's not a
clever strategy by the right and you
have people on the left using forms of
violence to protest this again
you are part of the problem and you're
actually gonna cause more harm than good
hmm so well barring the dare I say Alex
Jones like conspiracy theory that it was
some masked right winger let's assume
for a second that these were actual
liberals because they claim to be
liberal sure and they they were found to
be liberals
let's assume that for a second hmm I
would wonder why why would these
liberals think that being violent is
okay
is there any reason out there is it
possible just so happens we have an
exclusive we've unearthed some footage
from The Young Turks that the best
amount to the best of my knowledge
they've tried to scrub clean from the
internet this is from 2010 this came to
us Thank You Lee Doren his channel was
how the world works it only has like
15,000 plays on it so people seem to
have missed this I could be wrong
haven't found it anyone the Young Turks
channel here is after the violent
protests and riots that erupted in
France here is I want to spare I want to
say any to sarkeesian I don't in the
same Ana Kasparian straight from the
horse face looking mouth this is what
I'm talking about we need this in the
frickin United States of America why do
we not have protests like this I don't
care talking about violent protests it's
gonna be brutal and violent or whatever
we need this because politicians in the
US are not getting it through their
frickin heads and we have Republicans
right now and Senate and in the house
that are saying you know let's do away
with Social Security they're not saying
it explicitly but that is what they want
and they're saying yeah yeah why should
we retire at 65 let's make all these
[ __ ] retire at 70 no it's real
talk these protests get violent people
get hurt I understand that but that's
what democracy is all about it's about
fighting for your rights going out there
no I love it I love it I'm very proud of
the French right now so who would have
thought that when you would have given a
literal call to action violet leftists
would have taken it literally Anna and
here's something I hope people are
finally catching on because a lot of
people used to like Bernie until they
didn't used to give us flak they used to
like The Young Turks until now they
don't the left doesn't want to take
responsibility for their actions I know
you wanna say it's left versus right
pretty clearly The Young Turks
the left they are emblematic of the left
and whenever people say you know I was
with the Young Turks I used to be I mean
even her friends are gone of a cat I've
always maintained this argument same
thing with dave rubin who worked with
them and they say i used to be there but
until they went off the rails no no
that's the young turks in 2010 they
didn't go off the rails you're simply
off the rails with them you're now back
on the rails kinda like people said well
you know what I liked
until I find out no listen Bernie didn't
just all of a sudden become a social
justice warrior black lives matter white
privilege checking wage gap myth
perpetuating social justice leftist
prick
he didn't just with you he didn't just
wake up that day you just used to look
past that because of your hatred of
conservatives and desire for free stuff
but now now you've realized the Young
Turks didn't just all of a sudden wake
up and become free speech hating
politically correct ad hominem centered
Armenian genocide denying dishonest
social justice warrior protests they
were always that way
they were always that way so don't act
as though at some point try and cover
you oh yeah you know what I was with
them until that's 2010 that was when
they were getting started if you were
with them then you just didn't see them
for what they were if you were with
Bernie in the primaries you just didn't
see him for what he was
but now you've walked into reality and
you're very welcome to be here we are so
glad to have you if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than $6 a
month and you get daily content no more
clips Plus this hand etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside